Martial arts movies are their own brand of
fun.
Whether you're into well-choreographed action,
or just like watching chiseled warriors beat
each other up, your viewing choices are better
than ever.
To help you stock up your kung fu queue, here
some lesser-known martial arts movie stars
from around the world who deserve way more
recognition.
Ilram Choi
Described as one of Hollywood's "go-to stuntmen,"
Ilram Choi has been working behind the scenes
in the industry for over a decade.
Formally trained in taekwondo and a self-taught
master of gymnastics, Choi is responsible
for countless movie stunts you've seen since
2002.
Choi was one of Spider-Man's stunt doubles
in the Amazing Spider-Man movies.
In fact, he was so good at being Spider-Man,
he became the fight coordinator for Spider-Man:
Homecoming.
Choi has done stunt work for a bunch of video
games, too, most notably serving as the basis
of Albert Wesker's fighting style in Resident
Evil 5 as well as doing some of the stunts
from Devil May Cry 3.
Scott Adkins
This British actor is seemingly unable to
avoid being typecast as a Russian thug.
Trained mostly in kickboxing with a background
in taekwondo and gymnastics, Scott Adkins'
skills have recently been showcased during
his numerous fight scenes as Yuri Boyka, the
straight-to-DVD hero of the Undisputed movies.
All in all, Adkins seems to feel most at home
making cheesy direct-to-video movies with
even cheesier names like Ninja: Shadow of
a Tear.
Marko Zaror
Before he became an action star, Chilean actor
Marko Zaror initially made his foray into
the entertainment industry as a model.
Standing around pouting in a pair of jeans
didn't cut it, so he decided to try his hands
at punching people in Spanish B-movies.
From this his transitioned to bit parts in
Hollywood and Bollywood movies before finally
returning to his native Chile to become the
country's first real action star.
Vidyut Jammwal
The big break for Vidyut Jammwal came courtesy
of Commando: A One Man Army, in which he performed
all of his own stunts and choreographed his
own fights specifically to show off his martial
arts prowess.
Most critics considered Jamwal to be the film's
only real saving grace.
It was enough to get a sequel greenlit, which
looks even more ridiculous than the first
movie.
In addition to being recognized as a phenomenal
martial artist, Jammwal was declared PETA's
sexiest vegetarian in 2014.
Lateef Crowder
For anyone with a passing familiarity with
the Tekken franchise, Lateef Crowder is basically
Eddy Gordo.
In fact, Crowder's physical resemblance to
the character was so uncanny that he was the
only real choice to play him in the live-action
Tekken movie.
"Bring it on boy.
Come on!"
Along with appearing in terrible film adaptations
of popular video games, Crowder is a prolific
extra in movies when they need a thug who
can can do cool spin kicks.
As a result, footage exists of Crowder getting
beat up by everyone from Michael Jai White
to CGI wolves in the Twilight movies.
Sadly for such a capable martial artist, Crowder
is criminally under-utilized in most of his
film roles.
His greatest fight scene might just be his
earliest credited role in The Protector, which
saw him fighting against Tony Jaa.
Wu Jing
Even though he's never gotten the same recognition
as guys like Donnie Yen or Jackie Chan, Wu
Jing is an astonishingly accomplished martial
artist.
Known for his acrobatic fighting style, Jing
has mostly starred in Chinese action movies
with fun names like Metallic Attraction: Kungfu
Cyborg.
Wu Jing's bread and butter seems to be taking
kicks and punches for a few minutes before
ending his opponent with a 40-hit combo.
As an OG of the martial arts world, Wu Jing
has appeared in everything from cheesy '90s
action movies to gritty war films, and he
always delivers.
Johnny Nguyen
While Vietnamese martial artist Johnny Nguyen
has sporadically done stunt work in the U.S.
on projects like the original Spider-Man trilogy,
a live-action Mortal Kombat TV show, and X-Men:
First Class, most of his appearances come
from Vietnamese action movies.
If you've never heard of the guy and want
to ease into his kick-centric world, you could
do worse than 2009's Clash, in which he kicks
three people in the face at the same time,
all while wearing mom jeans.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!